okay so a guy named up here or Yvonne
Pierre a guar posted some photos to
Twitter yesterday these are photos of a
trip that Alexandria Kaiser Cortez took
to the border a year ago apparently and
we're told that she took the trip to the
border not for publicity or if actually
took a break from campaigning a break
from campaigning to go to the border and
to protest our immigration system
basically the photos are so
transparently staged and phony that it's
it's it's almost physically painful to
look at them it's difficult to look
because they are so contrived but let's
take a look at them anyway so here you
go here that here are the photos that
were posted I got a lot of retweets and
likes and people are saying that I was
it's well in fact some people were we're
very touched by these photos but there
are a lot of people even apparently aoc
supporters who said that come on you
know I'm the I like you but this is
ridiculous
so there's a occ you're standing next to
a fence looking right into the camera a
very sad disappointed kind of concerned
look on her face i that look right there
you see right that is a look that I get
for my wife a lot especially when I make
puns it says so it's a very familiar
look and then we have her right after
she looked into the camera now she's now
she's covering her face in despair and
and then now she's doubled over okay so
now she's really going in for the this
is the dramatic moment the climax but
she utterly overcome by despair now
she's doubled over covering her face
this actually looks like this looks like
me when I go to a bar and find out that
they only have Miller Lite and Coors on
tap it's a very similar like no those
beers taste like watered-down goat urine
so it's of a so I do the same thing I
understand that actually okay and now
here she is again now she's regained her
composure but she's still looking quite
sad and now though angry and disturbed
this is the look that I give when I'm
stuck in the car with all three kids and
they started singing songs from The
Wiggles this is the actually
no that's go back to the to the one of
her doubled over no that's me that's
actually me when I'm in the car and the
kids are singing so it's difficult to
drive it's a little bit dangerous for me
to be doing that well while driving
anyway so there those are the pictures I
mean it's it's just a joke now the
crisis down on our border is not a joke
that is a serious problem we're going to
talk about that today but she is making
a joke out of it by using it as a you
know this is very similar remember those
stories couple weeks ago of the
Instagram influencers who are showing up
at Chernobyl to take selfies sometimes
half nude selfies this is very similar
to that this is an essentially a
glorified Instagram influencer going to
the site of a real human travesty for
for a photo opportunity just disgraceful
well as I said there's more that needs
to be discussed about our border but
first a word from wives company you know
wise company freeze-dried food is very
easy to prepare and the best part is
that it can be stored for 25 years 25
years that is longer than I've been
alive I'm only 20 years old in case you
didn't know there are a lot of practical
benefits of that but but I think maybe
the greatest benefit to having that 25
years is the peace of mind that comes
with being prepared with food in case of
an emergency
emergencies come in many forms you know
hurricanes tornadoes earthquakes flood
wildfires wildfires power outages even
job loss something like that you may
need to be prepared for all of those
wise company takes an innovative
approach and providing dependable simple
and affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
you can't know what tomorrow is gonna
bring you don't know what the future is
gonna hold but you can't have peace of
mind knowing that you'll be ready for
whatever is on the way this week my
listeners get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra 25
percent off the lowest mark price at
wise food storage comm when entering
Walsh at checkout
or if you call eight five five four
seven five three zero eight nine plus
shipping is free so this can't get any
better wise has a well fact it does get
better because wise has a ninety day no
questions asked return policy so there's
no risk and taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family more prepared
today but I don't think you're gonna
want to repair return it because I don't
think you're gonna get the food and then
say to yourself you know what I don't
actually want to be prepared for an
emergency
I'll send it back if you love your
family anyway you wouldn't do that
that's wives food storage com promo code
Walsh to get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra twenty
five percent off and free shipping
all right the company wage Fair has been
the target of protests and outrage by
the left because it's selling furniture
to migrant detention centers in fact a
bunch of employees of the company over
five hundred of them are planning to
walk out today in in protest of it but
but wait a second I I thought we were
upset that the kids at these centers
don't have beds to sleep in and that is
upsetting I agree because they should
have beds right so now the centers are
getting beds and that's a problem too
you're protesting that they don't have
beds and then they get beds and you're
protesting also it it just it doesn't
make any sense over five hundred
employees signed a letter to the company
the letter says in part this particular
order for over two hundred thousand
dollars worth of bedroom furniture is
destined for Curry's Carrizo springs
Texas to a facility that will be
outfitted to detain up to three thousand
migrant children seeking asylum in the
United States so it sounds like this
this Detention Facility is trying to be
prepared it's it's it is outfitting
itself knowing you know if the people
running the facility know that there's
gonna be an influx of children so
they're trying to prepare and make sure
that they're they've got places for the
kids to sleep and stay that's good
that's what we want right it continues
the practice of detaining children and
adults on our southern border has been
condemned since its inception but the
but since the acceleration of the
practice in 2018 and the increase in
death and injury that
come with that acceleration we have seen
more vocal condemnation of the practice
we the undersigned are writing to you
from a place of concern and anger about
the atrocities being committed at our
southern border
they said condemned since its inception
Noah does not pit has not been condemned
since its inception because the left was
not condemning it during the Obama
administration and it was happening then
also now the way they get around is they
try to say oh yeah was happening during
Obama's administration we didn't talk
about it then we didn't care in fact not
only did we not talk about it but it
wasn't just that the left wasn't talking
about the crisis on the border back in
the Obama administration it's that they
were actively denying that there was a
crisis so now they're condemning it the
way they get around it is they say well
you know it's it's it's the problems
gotten worse since then okay the
problems gotten worse
you claim but so you're more concerned
now than you were before that would
justify being more concerned except that
you weren't concerned at all before you
went from 0 to 100 there was no 25 or 50
in between like there should have been
which really makes it seem like this is
political partisanship and the only
reason you're pretending to care now is
that Trump is president and they also
say that that whether they phrase it the
practice of detaining children is
condemned well
the mere fact that we are detaining
people is obviously not a problem and
you didn't think it was four years ago
and you were right the simple act of
detaining people is is there there are
scenarios where you need to do that it's
a problem when the conditions at these
facilities aren't up to par and
sometimes they're not but that but
that's where getting furniture getting
food and all that that means that we're
improving conditions and that's what
we're supposed to want the hypocrisy on
this issue the partisanship the lack of
real concern is infuriating because
there is a real crisis down there as I
said and that crisis comes with a
significant human cost in fact there's a
photo that has been all over social
media for the past day that really shows
that cost I think it shows two
immigrants from El Salvador excuse me
father and daughter apparently and
they're washed up on the shores of the
Rio Grande
both have died lying face down in the
water the young girl two years old has
her arm around her father's neck it's
just a it's a it's a devastating
gut-wrenching photo that you can't I
mean if you're a human being you can't
help but be moved when you see it
especially as a father myself well even
if I wasn't a father obviously I know I
would still know that it's tragic for
people to die especially children but as
a father I see this kind of stuff and
inevitably I'm gonna think of my own
kids and imagine my own kids in that
situation it's unspeakable I'm not gonna
show you the photo here because it's
extremely upsetting and not everyone
wants to see something like that but if
you do want to see it you can easily
find it online now this photo is being
used
and we could stop right there the
problem is that the photo is being used
it should be used for anything it's not
a political tool this is real life this
is real death this is something real
that's happening it's not it's not a
ammunition to be used in an argument or
it shouldn't be but that's how people
are treating it so it's being used to of
course make the case against Trump's
immigration politics or policies even
though again the problem didn't start
with Trump but aside from that Trump is
not responsible for this poor child's
death he didn't he didn't do that
there are many authorities many entities
that you could point the finger at Trump
is not one of them so how do we prevent
more of these tragedies when you do
everything we can to discourage illegal
border crossings crossing the border
illegally
is incredibly dangerous especially for
children children you have to deal with
the elements dehydration starvation
gangs bandits wild animals I mean
everything you can imagine you're trying
to cross a desert
sneak across the borders of a country
it's a very hazardous undertaking and
the best way to protect human life is to
discourage people from undertaking it in
the first place there are a lot of ways
to do that for one thing people I think
the first thing that needs to happen and
that this is not something that we can
from I primarily do but people should be
working with in the Central American
countries to improve conditions and
punish crime thus encouraging people to
stay I mean rather than having everyone
abandoned ship and leave their countries
which I understand the instinct to do
that and as again as a father you know
if I had kids and I happen to have the
bad luck of being born in one of those
countries and living one of the
countries I'd want to leave to I I think
I would yes on one hand if everyone
leaves that it makes it difficult to
clean up the problems within the
countries but so that's a
was a father I think I would say you
know what I'm more concerned about
taking care of my own children that I am
about enacting change generally in the
country my first responsibility is to my
kids so that's the case and I understand
that but the fact remains that it's a
self-perpetuating problem because these
these countries are in terrible shape
everybody wants to leave but everyone's
leaving so there's no one there there's
no one sticking around to fix the
problems and so then it just perpetuates
itself now when Trump famously said back
in back when he launched his campaign
that they're not sending their best
which is true in in some cases in some
cases we are getting criminals and drug
dealers and so on not all of them of
course but there is some of that and
it's a problem but when he said that
leftist we're very outraged and they
insisted that no they are sending their
best they're sending good law-abiding
hard-working people and I agree that a
certain significant portion of these
people fall into that category but you
see the problem here those people are
coming here if they are good law-abiding
hard-working then those are exactly the
kinds of people that these countries
need in order to clean themselves up
especially when you've got now we talk
about the kids and the families coming
over and because that's what affects us
emotionally the most but the fact
remains when you look at these caravans
of people and everything many of them
are our single young men and those
people especially are the kinds of
people they're physically healthy strong
capable don't have any dependents young
men got people like that those
especially are the people who need to
stay or or whose countries need them to
stay to stay there and help rebuild it
so
but how do we get people says it's a
self-perpetuating problem people are
leaving makes the problem worse how do
we get people to stay well we'll talk
about that but but before we get into
that I want to thank our sponsors over a
dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquitoes and
insect traps and now they've come up
with a solution for indoor pests because
you know when when in the in the
summertime this is one of the most
annoying things you have to deal with
summer is great but I'm not actually a
big fan of summer but some people like
the summertime for some reason if you
like it to be hot and you're sweating
all the time and and if you if you enjoy
that and also if you like insects inside
your home because that's another thing
that comes with summer it's a very
annoying problem and when you have those
insects flying around especially flies
you know flies when they when they land
on your food they vomit on your food did
you know that I'm pretty sure that's
true I saw it on Wikipedia I think
either way you don't want them on your
food so what do you do about that well
that's where the dynatrap fly light
comes into play forget those disgusting
fly strips the little sticky things
where the flies light land forget about
that the dynatrap fly light looks like a
subtle nightlight that plugs into any
indoor outlet I've been using the
dynatrap fly light for a couple days now
a couple weeks now really and it's just
insane the number of insects that these
things catch and and they really do
clean up the problem get yours at
dynatrap comets DUI in ATR AP comm enter
the promo code walsh and receive 15% off
any of their products dynatrap is the
safe silent simple solution to household
insect control all right so we're
talking about what can be done to
minimize the human cost the human
tragedy crisis on the border and one of
those ways I think with the main way is
to get people to discourage illegal
immigration in the first place and the
way that you do that is we shut down the
border
we we enforce our immigration laws we
deport people yes we stop offering
entitlements to illegals in fact we make
it clear that if you come here illegally
you're not gonna get entitlements we
make it clear that if you come here
illegally it's not gonna work you won't
be able to sneak in yes we build a wall
we build a physical barrier that's going
to make it even more difficult it's just
yet another roadblock in the way we do
all of that that's how we preserve human
life we want people to think this this
is to try to come here illegally is a
dangerous potentially fatal decision if
we care about human life and if we're
compassionate if we care about these
people then we want to discourage them
from doing that and this is how we
discourage them but if we insist on
keeping the borders open on just
welcoming anyone not enforcing our
immigration laws saying anyone can come
in then all you're doing is you're
encouraging more people like that father
to try to bring their their children on
on such a dangerous journey and more
people are gonna die
all right um let's let's talk about this
as we have established repeatedly the
left is now beyond parody at this point
impossible to but you can't satirize
them anymore it's just impossible to do
and here's exhibit 45,000 in to
demonstrate that BBC Radio 4's Saturday
Review show did a segment on Toy Story 4
which just came out last week and which
I'm which I'm looking forward to taking
my kids to but apparently maybe I
shouldn't take my kids because it is a
racist sexist movie that also
discriminates against disabled people
apparently that's according to Stella
Duffy who's a film critic I guess she
came on the show
to share her thoughts on the film a film
that in case you didn't know is animated
it's an animated children's movie about
talking toys in case you were unaware of
what Toy Story is that's what it is and
this is what she had to say about it
listen to this hello my name is Stella
Duffy and I didn't like Toy Story 4 I'm
the Grinch who hated it
seriously it's 2019 what on earth are
Disney doing having a film that for a
start has no leads that are black
characters yes there are black actors
here but we do not they're yellow and
they're green and they're plush how can
they possibly think it's all right
now I mean yeah maybe 1995 which was
also wrong then as well actually but now
to be seriously every single humanoid
toy is white it's just shocking then
let's talk about the white feminism on
display here oh look Bo peeps are
feminists no she's not she's still gonna
fall in love she's still gonna get all
habit not spoiling still gonna get all
happily ever after that's not feminism
that's a woman's kicks off a skirt to
reveal bloomers has a couple of thoughts
does some high wire acts and it's
disabled
it's covering every base okay so there
you go it's it's racist sexist disabled
list disabled us I thought ablest was
the term so ablest is when you
discriminate against disabled people
it's so then disabled list I guess is
when you descript discriminate against
non-disabled people i well anyway she's
upset that there are also no black leads
okay but all the leads are toys which
means they're all Chinese either Chinese
or they have no race at all because
they're toys I mean one of the lead
characters is a toy slink is like a
slinky dog another is a green dinosaur
another is up is a pink piggy bank
another is a mr. Potato Head what what
ethnicity is a mr. Potato Head Irish I
mean what that doesn't make any sense
should the film what do you want you
want the Phil
so even though we've got all these toys
who have no race no ethnicity you're
saying there should be a black lead in
the film so do you want should the film
feature like a miniature real-life black
person should this suddenly become Honey
I Shrunk the kids and in a black person
the size of a doll walks on and you know
interacts with the toys just so we can
check off that demographic box
it's obviously absurd and this is this
is really mental illness this that
person you just heard is mentally ill
clearly and I mean that sincerely I mean
I'm concerned about her and she has a
problem because Little Bo Peep falls in
love the characters fall in love imagine
how bitter and sad and and lonely you
have to be to get ticked off that the
characters in an animated children's
movie fall in love but this is you know
what I I like to write satire articles
sometimes I'll write satirical pieces
for the daily wire and if someone had
suggested to me two weeks ago that I
write a satirical article complaining
that Toy Story is racist because there
are no black leads I would have said no
I'm not gonna do it because that's
that's obviously too absurd Oh glad
that's that's too far out there for a
satire to work you want it to be it has
to be it has to be a little absurd like
it out you whatever your satirizing
you're taking that line of thinking that
you know philosophy and you're just
taking it to an extreme to demonstrate
the inherent absurdity of that that line
of thinking but I would have thought
well that's too extreme you know that's
I mean they wouldn't really come on like
that's a straw man they wouldn't really
come but no they they really are
complaining that Toy Story is racist
because there are no plaque there are no
black toys by the way Toy Story 4 you
might try to justify this by saying well
maybe she means that there are no black
voice actors but that isn't true
um key & peele are are in that they are
voice actors in this movie they voice to
plush plush dolls but the problem is
that the dolls are not black the dolls
are like blue and pink or something just
absolutely ridiculous alright so one
other thing to mention before we get to
emails
San Francisco a city that resembles a
large outhouse at this point has decided
to really focus on the important issues
it has banned the use and sale of
e-cigarettes and vape pens now I'm
pretty sure that you can essentially
legally shoot up heroin in San Francisco
I don't know IV I don't know if that's
actually the law in the books I'm not
recommending it I'm just saying that
people do that anyway and it's they
don't seem to be arrested for it they
also you know defecate on the sidewalks
so you could do all of that without much
fear of legal repercussions but no you
can't you can't smoke a cigarette or
vape the mayor this is the reason the
mayor gave for the band
the mayor said there's so much we don't
know about the health impacts of these
products but we do know that each
cigarette companies are targeting our
kids and they're advertising and getting
them hooked on addictive nicotine
products ok so did you catch that we
don't know the health impacts and that's
why we're gonna ban it yeah we don't
know much about this better ban it just
in case yeah you know there could be a
problem with it we haven't even so we
don't know so let's say I will just ban
it ban it and ask questions later that's
that's the philosophy now of the nanny
Staters listen I don't smoke
e-cigarettes
I don't vape I I do tend to think that
vaping it's not for me
I think vaping looks kind of ridiculous
if you're gonna smoke I think to you
know smoke like a man smoke a cigar
that's not a real recommendation kids
I'm that don't smoke at all I'm just
saying that if you I mean if you had to
choose if someone put a gun to your head
and said smoke one of these I would say
go for the cigar so
you know this is not sound like I'm
trying to defend something that I do
because I don't use these cigarettes but
it's just when are we gonna get it
through our heads here that this kind of
nanny state approach does not work
you're only when you do this you're only
making whatever you're banning you're
just making it seem cooler and maybe at
a certain point we have to just accept
the fact that we're not gonna ever stop
all the teenagers from smoking something
it's just it's the reality seems like I
mean just looking at the human history
at least modern human history the
teenagers the some of them are always
there's gonna be something that they're
smoking so yeah we got them we got them
this so it used to be back in the you
know 70s and 80s that all the teenagers
smoked cigarettes and then we we
embarked on this 20-year
campaign to stop people from smoking
cigarettes and that kind of worked and
so then they just graduated to
e-cigarettes and vapes like there's
always gonna be something and I think at
a certain point we have to just realize
that and except it doesn't mean we
doesn't mean we stop discouraging it it
just means we stop trying to stop it by
force of law with regulations and fines
and penalties and all that because
really at the end of the day that's
regulations and fines and penalties and
laws
that's not actually what what stopped
kids from smoking cigarettes I think the
main thing you know well the the the
main thing was just was just
discouraging it just by pointing out
like yeah you can do it but it causes
cancer it's gonna make your teeth yellow
so on and so forth just hammering on
that and then people chose not to and
also I think when when 'men effect when
you stop seeing so much smoking on TV
and the celebrities weren't doing it
quite as much that it didn't seem as
cool to the kids and so they didn't do
it but what I'm trying to point out here
is that the there's the cool factor is
big with kids
and that's the reason why they why they
were all smoking in the 80s because it
was just a cool thing to do the problem
is and trying to make something less
cool is difficult that's a that's a when
you are an uncool adult and which we all
are uncool as adults and you notice
something the kids are doing that is
destructive yet they think is cool and
you're saying to yourself I want to make
that thing uncool it's really difficult
to do because you're uncool so whatever
you say about it the more you complain
about it you're just making the thing
cooler you see that's the way the
equation works so it's a difficult trick
to pull pull I think that it was
basically pulled off with cigarettes it
took a long time but one thing I know
for sure is that you're not gonna make
something less cool by making it illegal
that I'm a hundred percent certain all
right we're going to talk about it we're
gonna get to some emails here in a
minute but before we do a quick word
about shaving did you know that the
average guy spends 3,000 hours of his
lifetime shaving which is an interesting
statistic I don't know where they get it
from I've always thought to myself that
this is one thing that I hope that when
we die and were you know kind of in that
big waiting room in the sky waiting to
go and talk to the big man and find out
which direction we're headed right and
we're all just kind of soon as I imagine
it being like a big dentist like waiting
room there's a couple of old magazines
so maybe out-of-date magazines from
seventeen thirty or something but I what
I hope is that while we're there maybe
they give us a fun little packet that
has a bunch of just interesting
statistics about our life like this is
how many hours you spent shaving this is
how many days you spend sleeping that
kind of thing this is how many gallons
of orange juice you drank and you're
like just random things I always hope
that anyway 3,000 hours of the life
shaving don't don't waste four months of
your life overpaying for pork for poor
performing razors that's where Harry's
comes in get Harry's a razor that's so
sharp you can shave less often and
you'll save money it's just $2 per blade
I use Harry's myself because I do shave
contrary to pop
believe I got to shave the the neck and
you know around here so I don't look
like Chewbacca and the thing I love
about Harry's is that number one the
price razors are ridiculously expensive
usually these are not number two it's a
very smooth and close shave I don't even
have to use shaving cream when I do it
you could join the ten million people
who have tried Harry's claim your
special offer by going to harrys.com
slash Matt Walsh
you know Harry's founders were two
regular guys tired of getting ripped off
paying for overpriced gimmicks vibrating
heads flex balls handles that look like
something from a sci-fi movie or
whatever Harry's makes quality durable
blades at a fair price that's just two
dollars a bit a blade you can get a
trial set that comes with everything you
need for a close comfortable shave
weighted her gonna her gonna make handle
for an easy grip five blade razor with
laser razor with a lubricating strip a
trimmer blade for a close-up shave
listeners of my show can redeem their
trial set at harrys.com slash matt walsh
and if you prefer to shop in-store you
can go to Walmart and Target and get
harry's there as well
all right let's answer some emails Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com this is from Denise says hi
Matt thank you for the witty sarcasm you
add to my life every day I am wondering
if you believe in spanking young
children as a form of discipline do you
spank your own children well Denise
that's a tough question because I'm of
two minds when it comes to this well I
could tell you what we do that's not
tough we don't spank am i against
spanking on principle I suppose I'm not
the Bible does say spare the rod spoil
the child and people use that as a
justification for spanking or even
people will use that to make the case
that we are morally obliged to spank
but the problem though is that
if you're claiming to take that verse
totally literally then that means that
you must hit your kid with a rod do you
use an actual rod do you take out like a
metal rod just to spank your kid because
if you don't and probably you don't
hopefully you don't then you are
literally sparing the rod I mean in a
literal sense you are defying that
particular passage because you are not
using a rod to hit your kid so I my
point is that I think even those of us
who spank I think we all kind of take
that passage in a more general way to
mean don't don't spoil your kid don't
coddle your kid too much instill
discipline you know that's that's the
way that I take it I don't take it as we
are somehow committing a sin if we don't
spank our kids I just tell you my thing
with it I could never quite bring myself
to see
as a parenting technique and I know that
calling it violence is is gonna upset
people who spank their kids it seems
extreme maybe it is an extreme way of
putting it I mean it is but it is you're
physically hitting someone right so that
are there I don't know I mean it is
violence technically speaking
now spanking if it's really spanking and
not beating spanking is and this is
wearing maybe you say well it's not
really violence because it's not about
inflicting physical pain now there may
be a little bit physical pain but that's
not the point the point isn't look if
you're just grabbing your kid because
you're ticked off and you're just
looking to let out your aggression and
so you start spanking him well then
that's physical abuse you're abusing
your kid you're a physical abuser in
that case in fact I would go so far as
to say just if you spank your kid angry
you are physically abusing that is
you're hitting your kid because you're
pissed off that's what that is and that
is definitely wrong but what about a
scenario where you're not angry you're
calm down you're not doing this because
you're trying to make your kid hurt but
it's just it is a form of discipline and
you approach it yourself in a
disciplined way in a sort of
businesslike way like look this is the
penalty so I'm gonna spank you I'll give
you a hug afterwards because I love you
but this is the penalty I think if we
talk about the non abusive spanking
that's what it has to be unfortunately
though just from talking to people it
seems like a lot of parents that's not
really what spanking is for them they
may say that it is but really it's
they're ticked off and that again is
abusive so you know but but let's let's
talk about the spanking where it's your
you're approaching it from a disciplined
point a perspective and and it's it's
not just anger well no I don't think
that the parents that spank that way are
abusing their kids but I still just
choose not to do it
and I think because I could never for me
it always seemed like if I spanked and I
get the kids to behave based on that
then then basically the implied threat
is do what I want or I'll hit you and
again I know that's not what parents are
literally saying to their kids at least
I hope they're not that's not the
intention but I personally couldn't get
past seeing it that way and one thing
that I've learned as a parent is if
something just doesn't feel right to you
if it if it doesn't if it doesn't feel
right for your family
um for your situation then listen to
your gut follow your instincts I think
if you follow your gut if you follow
your instincts you'll be right about 98%
of the time as a parent it seems to me
so I'm I'm not sitting in judgment of
parents who do use corporal punishment
my parents did not that much but they
used it I'm not traumatized by it I
don't feel like I was abused
you know I survived I'm fine but still
it just didn't seem right to me so it I
don't do it I have my reasons for not
doing it which I've tried to sort of in
a babbling way explain but I think I do
believe that there is a inappropriate
way of going about it and parents who do
that have my blessing not that they need
it alright from Rebecca
says hi Matt do you believe in ghosts
just curious if it's a belief that
clashes with our Christian faith I think
it does clash with our Christian faith
now if by ghost you mean demonic spirits
then yeah I believe in that that doesn't
clash but if you mean the souls of dead
people who are just sort of wandering
around on earth randomly that I think it
does present a contradiction or at least
a problem theologically because you're
you die and you stand before God and and
then it's decided
which direction you're gonna head it's
hard for me to see how God would allow
some Souls to just walk around on earth
scaring people like what's the point of
God really do that because that there
could be there can't be any ghosts who
are here by accident that has to be
through God's will so does God really
send a soul back to earth back to some
old creepy house to walk around and
scare children
you know if I was God then maybe I would
do that just for fun but I'm not God and
I think that God is not nearly as petty
as I am thankfully this is from Johnny
says hello mr. Lord Walsh well you don't
have to call me that
Lord walls just fine this is a very
upfront but difficult for me question
it's something that I've been struggling
with for a while and I think it's
something that might have ruined my past
relationship of three years what is love
is there an objective death definition
can scripture back it up well if you
want to answer that question I think
share listen to that share song what is
love it she really provides the answer
if I had to elaborate on that answer I
would say I would second secondarily I
would quote after share Thomas Aquinas
who said that love to love is to will
the good of the other and I think that's
the best definition that anyone has ever
come up with and I think that if you
read scripture you're going to find that
that's the that's the definition offered
not a direct directly but all throughout
scripture you know and that's one as I
as I as I sometimes say about quoting
from the Bible or using a Bible
we can't always look for one sentence
which just sort of parrots whatever
point we're trying to make I think that
I think we have to we have to look at
the totality of Scripture we have to
look at the whole sort of story that's
being told and we have to take a more
comprehensive view of it and so with a
question like what is love I think
you're gonna find that this answer love
is to will to go to the other that is
all throughout the Bible that's the
answer that you get that's how love is
portrayed and what that means is I mean
it's pretty straightforward it means
that if you love someone then you want
what is best for them and you not only
want it but as Aquinas says to Willet
meaning you're going to do what you can
to help bring about what is best for
them now in order for your work for you
to have a properly ordered and healthy
and good love then you have to have a
correct understanding of what is best
for someone I think there are people who
have an incorrect understanding of what
is best so they love people but in but
they have a incomplete sort of
misdirected love because they don't
understand what's actually best for the
human person the ultimate goal of the
human person is to go to heaven so
ultimately if you love someone that
means you want them to go to heaven and
you're going to do whatever you can in
your own way to help them in that quest
that's what it means to love someone now
we can get into the Greek and start
breaking down the different are we
talking about agape love are we talking
about
eros oh you know what kinds of love are
we talking about there so the charitable
love there's the erotic romantic love
brotherly love you know the Greeks had
different words for love which is good
because we only have the one and they
can get confusing sometimes but the
common thread that ties together all
those forms of love is that you are
willing the good of the other
as a follow-up to that I think the sad
reality is that there are a lot of
people out there who don't love anyone
because I think there are a lot of
people who really don't will the good of
anyone but themselves they really don't
at the end of the day there are a lot of
people who really don't care that much
if anyone else
you know his ends up going to heaven or
or gets or you know gets it's the good
things in life I think there are a lot
of people just don't care about that
they're focused on themselves and so
they might we'll the good for you
insofar as it will help them so in a min
if you're if you're a selfish person in
a marriage you may sometimes act in a
way that looks loving it has the
appearance of love but really what
you're doing is you're just trying to
make the other person happy because it's
easier for you if they're happy so
you're trying to sort of satiate them
because it's gonna be easier for you or
you're doing them a favor you're doing a
good thing for them because you want
them to do you a favor or because you
just want credit for it or because you
want to emotionally blackmail them later
you can say yeah remember what I did
that thing for you and now you're doing
this to me how dare you so there's a lot
of that that goes on marriages I think
there are a lot of marriages where
really there is no love because neither
spouse is really willing the good of the
other for the sake of the other maybe
that's the addendum we should add to
will the good of the other for the sake
of the other not for your own sake so
that is I think love thank you for the
question no and thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
we prepare for the first democratic
debate and the media get hypocritical
about illegal immigration and crisis
today on the Ben Shapiro show